When there are grave disagreements about whats good or bad in architecture and art,
there is often someone around who is keen to quickly close the discussion down,
by saying
"Beauty lies in the eye of the beholder"
its a phrase with the power to silence.
Once its been uttered adding anything else
can seem a bit shrill or just plain rude.
But in reality, the idea that beauty
could be entirely subjective
is troublesome, quite untrue
and plain dangerous.
For a start,
no one believes it.
At the extremes of the argument,
we know that some things simply are,
just uglier than others.
And we can tell by looking at tourist figures
that certain places do strike millions of people
as far prettier than others.
If the will of the majority can be respected in politics
then it should also be respected in aesthetics.
Even in more ambiguous situations,
progress towards some sort of resolution
can be made.
By using careful logic and patient argument
After all, that's what we do with other big topics
like how to run the economy
or evaluate a hospital
or identify which one of two restaurants might be the better.
We may not be able to reach a conclusion that's scientifically proven
but non-scientific agreement can be acceptable too.
We don't need evidence from laboratories to agree on
the importance of family
or the intelligence of Shakespeare.
or the charm of the Alps.
So why insist that beauty in art and architecture
should be an impossible subject
to have any clear views about?
The answer is
actually rather sinister
The people who love our doubts about beauty
are one group in particular-
Property Developers.
Its extremely convenient for them to
operate in a society that has no confidence
in people's ability to make judgements
about whether things are beautiful or ugly.
If there's no such thing as an objective measure of beauty,
then you can pretty much do whatever you like to
a city or a landscape
and that's a lot cheaper.
We shouldn't let a few areas of doubt
over beauty, whether this or that
chair is more or less handsome, for example.
Hijack the wider argument
and lead to the reckless conclusion
that all beauty is always relative.
We must learn to stick up publicly and
sensibly for things
that a vast majority of us
can see is more
beautiful.
So that we don't get exploited
and end up being condemned
to living in the ugly environments
that have become so painfully common.